Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Wataruto Yokawa. He's unit
leader at the Computational Group Dynamics Collaboration Unit at
RCN CBS Tokyo. His research focuses on the computational
underpinnings and eco evolution. Eco-evolutionary implications of human social
learning and their relationships with group decision making and
collective behavior. And today we're going to explore topics
like social learning, collective decision making, the wisdom of
crowds, and other related topics. So Dr. Toyokawa, welcome
to the show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Hi Ricardo, thanks for having me. This is such
an honor to talk to you.
Well, thank you. Thank you so much. I really
appreciate that. So, uh, let me start with this.
Um, WHAT is social learning, uh, which aspects of
it are you most interested in and perhaps also,
uh, tell us. If, uh, perhaps I can ask
you uh it as a second, as a second
question, but tell us also a little bit about
the methodology that you, you use to study social
learning.
Right, right, yeah. Yeah, of course, yeah, so social
learning, uh, well, literally it's, it's learning, um, but
that is influenced by observing others or learning that
is, uh, shaped by interacting with other individuals, usually
the same species like con-specific individuals, but like, you
know, it could be extended to other. Asians. But
anyway, like this social learning is widely defined as
this uh learning process that is somehow um related
to some social uh situations. Um, SO that which
means that covers a huge range of behaviors such
as copying what someone does or just paying attention
to, uh, the other's behavior or like paying attention
to who succeeds or who fails at some tasks.
Or following the, the majority's opinions or sometimes we
defer, defer to experts advice or, you know, something
like that. So, yeah, I, I find it, social
learning is really exciting topic or exciting phenomenon because
social learning is uh one of, one of the
main drivers of, you know, collective level behavior and
cultural evolution. So, yeah, in a nutshell, um, social
learning. Create sort of feedback processes and biases in
the information transmission in the population. Uh, SO which
means some behaviors spread through a population while some
other, uh, behaviors might be suppressed or disappear, uh,
due to the, uh, you know, the social learning
processes or copying processes. Um, SO yeah, this means
social learning is not only about how individual acquire
information, but for me, social learning is interesting because
uh this also shape kind of how culture evolves
and how social norms and technologies uh kind of
fat fat and faster dynamics uh all emerges at
the group level. So, yeah.
Uh, uh, AND I, and I mean, uh, yeah,
just to, uh, ask you again the, or remind
you of the, of my question, yeah, the, the
second part, and there's, there's also the third part,
but the second part, I mean, which aspects of
social learning are you most interested in?
Yeah, right, so, yeah, that, for me, um, you
know, it's interesting because social learning, by definition is
just a one way of learning, right? Like a
learning by social social ways. But this kind of
automatically means that. Once animals or human individuals employing
some social learning processes, then it starts creating a
feedback processes and collective level dynamics due to the
interactive uh nature of uh social learning individuals. So,
I, I'm very interested in this, uh. I, I'd
like to disentangle uh between how individuals behave and
how, as a result, how collective level pattern emerges.
So, yeah, this kind of seemingly complicated and sometimes
nonlinear relationship between these two layer is interesting and
this is why I got interested in social learning
process.
Uh, AND, uh, I mean, what kinds of methodologies
do you use in your work to study social
learning.
Primarily, I'm then basically interested in the, the nature
of uh this collective dynamics emerging from social learning
strategies. Um, BUT I am particularly interested in human
social learning because um because humans are not blind,
kind of, uh, not random imitators. You know, we
are known to be kind of surprisingly strategic about.
Uh, ABOUT, uh, how, how we use social information.
So sometimes, uh, you know, we, without even realizing
it, we, we sometimes ask, like, is my own,
is my own information good enough or is this
person likely to know something that I do not
know? This type of, uh, you know, then we
would. Like we would choose the timing uh at
which we want to copy others and also we,
we usually select someone we want to copy from.
So, this kind of strategic use of social learning
is very uh remarkable in human behavior. Um, SO,
I'd like to understand, uh, that patterns and Why
we do that, how we do that, uh, by,
uh, combining both, uh, modeling, like computational modeling, as
well as, uh, running some behavior-based experiment. These days,
I usually use online game experiments. Um, SO, kind
of, yeah, I recruit, um. A bunch of people,
uh, human participants, uh, joining the, the, my, my,
our task online and, and then I, uh, just
organize some kind of a simple multiplayer, uh, online
game, multiplayer games, uh, where, where people hopefully enjoy
some decision-making tasks there and while I'm getting some
data from that.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, but that kind of approach
that you use, I mean, what kind of information
can we draw from it when it comes to
Uh, how people learn socially, I mean, uh, what
kinds of, for example, limitations would you say it
has when comparing to how people would learn from
others in a more sort of a natural environment
or in, in an environment that would be, of
course, I'm not. One thing to imply here that
uh doing or having that kind of methodology is
not ecologically valid, but you know, something that would
be perhaps closer to how we learn socially in
a more in a way that is closer to
how we do it in the real world, let's
say.
Right, yeah, um. So for sure, there are various
ways to uh to mimic uh real world complexity
in, in sort of tasks, but um I'm, I'm
particularly interested in the Kind of so-called exploration versus
exploitation dilemma in decision making. So usually like uh
this is like a very common feature of like
learning and decision making in animals, including humans obviously.
Uh, YOU know, because we have limited time and
we have limited resource and lifetime is limited, right?
So we are basically have to choose. Kind of
timing or circumstances where where we should go for
exploration to get more information versus uh we should
uh sometimes switch to use that knowledge we have
collected so far because otherwise, otherwise there's no point
to, to learn things, right? Because when you learn
something, you have to, you have to leverage that
knowledge, you have to use it wisely, right? So
then the question is, uh, you know, how we,
how animals are we. Have a, a kind of,
we, we usually balance this exploration and exploitation, and
also, uh, in theoretically speaking, uh, we can ask.
What kind of strategy should be adaptive, uh, and
what kind of balance between exploration and exploitation should
be optimal, uh, at the given circumstances, for example.
So, uh, because I'm interested in this kind of
nature of the general, uh, the common nature in,
uh, animal decision making. So I'm therefore have been,
I have been focusing on. Uh, THE so-called kind
of reinforcement learning tasks, uh, like called multi-arm bandit
program. So that is just a very toy model,
that is very abstract, uh, gambling task kind of,
but it's not necessarily gambling, but, um, it's, let's
say you are the casino player. Right, or you
know, then you have, uh, you have, you have
multiple slot machine options in front of you, right,
then your, your aim is to gather more coins
from, from playing the piano, playing the slot machines.
Right, so but you don't know which slot machine
is optimal, you don't know which slot machine is
good and which one is bad. At the at
at the outset, you don't have any information. So
you should therefore have to, you should, you have
to play some slot. And then get some experience
of like getting some reward or didn't get reward
at all and this kind of repeated experience is
eventually shaping your understanding about the world, understanding about
which slot machine seems to be good and which
slot machine seems to be bad. So this kind
of information, active information gathering processes and decision making
processes are kind of. This, like in this process
itself is kind of called multi unbounded task in
this uh kind of uh ndi uh theoretical world.
And then of course that kind of task is
very abstract, but thanks to that, thanks to this
abstraction, uh, we can capture uh various range of
real world situations ranging from, uh, animal foraging, for
example. Uh, OR like, uh, which, uh, which stock,
uh, you should invest in the long run, or,
I don't know, uh, like a mating, uh, made
choice decision making perhaps is also could be captured
some partly by this sort of reinforcement learning process.
So, yeah, so obviously there's a kind of a
trade-off between abstraction and, uh, focusing on more realistic.
Uh, CONCRETE programs in societies, but, um, I'd like
to kind of, yeah, there's 11 extreme. I'm taking
kind of one of, one side of the extreme,
like, uh, going to the very abstract, uh, program
in a way.
So I, I mean, this might seem like an
obvious, uh, I, I mean the answer to this
might seem obvious to many people, but why do
we learn from others? I mean, why is it
that we rely on others for information? I mean,
what do we get from others that we couldn't
just get from ourselves, let's say.
Yeah, that's actually really excellent question. It's, I don't
think it's kind of obvious, uh, to answer. Well,
intuitively, yeah, it's obviously, uh, we, we learn from
others because, you know, it's, it's a very easy
way to learn something, right? We learn, uh, from
others, uh, because the world environment is too large
or, you know, the skill we need are too
complex. And the environment is like too often very
uncertain or very costly to explore if you are
alone. So every individual, you know, this is due
to the again, the fact, due to the fact
that every individual having limited time, limited resource, a
limited attention window, right? So then. So in this
sense, we can see other people or other individuals
as a distributed sensors er in this environment. Because
they have, they might have already tried things that
you haven't tried yet or that you, for example,
uh, other, other people might have failed at things
already that you don't want to fail at by
yourself. Uh, AND also some, some might have discovered
new opportunities, uh, that you might otherwise miss. So.
And instead of yourself, if there are many other
individuals around you, then you, someone else can, might
have got some information and then if you can
simply observe that or use that, then it's one
of the cheapest way, like safest or cheapest way
to obtain the information. Um, THAT'S the kind of
intuitive, uh, one, I think, uh, that's obviously like,
that's true. It's, it's one of the, the huge
benefit from social learning. Um, BUT, um, social learning
is Yeah, although this is partly about. Reducing the
cost of exploration. Um, BUT I'd like to say
like I, I, I think. It's, it's important not
to describe social learning merely as. Information on free
riding sort of thing, right? Uh, OF course this
is cheap, uh, but. If this is just a
cheap, cheap. You know, the being cheap is one
of the, just the sole uh benefit from social
learning. Then this is a, this is true for
everyone else as well. So then people just start.
Copying each other and then because it's cheap, or
I'd like to go to the cheaper way and
then. And then it end up everyone just being
copying others, and then no one would explore new
things and no one would uh go to the
environment, taking the risk. So that's kind of dead
end. Um, BUT we know that social learning, uh,
have been generating, uh, like a culture evolution in
human histories driven by social learning, and we also
kind of intuitively think that, well, we kind of
do, do very well thanks to social learning. So,
yeah, and then this intuition is actually true, I
guess. So because social learning is not just information
free riding, I'd say, um. Because Uh, then, like,
the interesting part of social learning is coming in.
Um, SOCIAL learning is usually a, uh, more kind
of strategic and flexible process, uh, and You know,
When people use social learning strategically and interactively, um,
as maybe we, we, we're gonna discuss this, uh,
in the later, but, um, this can create kind
of synergistic benefit in the collective level, um, because
like intuitively like social learning can guide people, people's
future exploration. And then, therefore, It's not just like
it's not just free riding others finding, but it's
actually. Uh, BY following, by copying others' behavior, this
would guide you, this would tell you which direction
you should explore, and then, which means your individual
exploration behavior would be improved by the social, social
effect, social learning processes. So this actually this benefit
can accumulate uh by. Interactive processes between individual exploration
and social learning. And, so, so this interaction I
guess is key, and this is the key main
driver of so-called collective intelligence.
Right, but I mean, of course, uh people, or
at least I don't think people just er choose
to randomly get information from anyone, right? I mean
they have some criteria. I, I, I mean, what,
what kind of, are there, for example, er biases,
any kind of cognitive shortcuts like. Heuristics that are
cues that people uh look into or that perceive
when it comes to who they should acquire particular
information from. I mean, uh, are there, for example,
uh, social cues like uh the social identity of
someone, whether it whether it is because the person
is. Is older or the gender of the person
or for example the person has high status or
the person is has particularly high status when it
comes to certain kinds of topics or particular kinds
of information and so it's a reliable source of
information. I mean what. Kinds of cues or or
criteria do people use to decide, I mean, whether
consciously or subconsciously that OK, if I want to
learn more about this, these are the people I
should trust. I mean how do people go about
that?
Mhm, YEAH, yeah, yeah, so I think. The, the
like a various. Uh, OBVIOUSLY, there are multiple, uh,
wide range of different ways in which we, uh,
we rely on others, we, we copy others. Um,
BUT, uh, the literature has, uh, kind of sorted
because there are wide range of possible different ways
of, uh, collect, uh, social learning strategies, social learning,
uh. Like a use of social cues. Um, SO
the literature has, uh, sorted out, uh, uh, these
multiple strategies into basically roughly three categories. Uh, SO
one is like, uh, when strategies that regulate, like
when you should copy, when you copy. Uh, SECOND
one is who strategy, like, uh, regulate from whom
you should copy. Then the third one is what
strategy that regulates, uh, what kind of information you,
you should copy. And then. So there are two,
yeah, the, I think it's important to differentiate between,
uh, what human, what, what kind of strategy do
humans use and, and, uh, and, and what kind
of strategy would, strategy would be, uh, beneficial or
optimal under the given circumstances. Right, because humans are
not necessarily optimized to, to use. Uh, THE best
way of social learning under the given circumstances. So.
Um, FOR the As a, as a fact or
or like as a, as a pattern of human
behavior, uh, the, yeah, bunch of experimental empirical studies
in uh human uh social, social psychologies and uh
behavioral, behavioral sciences, um, including my, uh, my own
previous work. Um, MY previous studies have, uh, basically
focused on kind of conformity by social learning, that
is, uh, kind of humans sometimes dis disproportionately copying
the majority, like, you know, people sometimes follow the
majority more likely, uh, uh, you know, more disproportionately
likely, uh, uh, compared to the actual proportion of
the majority size. And then this sort of conformityized
social learnings are uh emerging more uh when, for
example, like uh decision making tasks, tasks are difficult
and people rely start relying more on those type
of social learning when groups became larger. So, human
social learning is, is really flexible. Uh, SO we,
we change how, how to use social learning, how,
how, how we follow others depending on, uh, the
given environment or social circumstances. So, uh, so which
means it's, it's really hard to say, uh, what
kind of cues human usually use because it depends
on the context. But, um, but other, uh, well,
well studied. Patterns be, uh, yeah, it's the empirical
bunch of empirical experiments have shown that people uh
pay attention to, um, others' success, so which is
called, um, success-based or payoff biased, uh, social learning,
um, so which is, uh, also like again widely
beneficial because It's, it's generally a good idea to
follow successful individuals. So people would pay attention to
those others, others, uh, success states. But um, but
it. It can also be misleading sometimes, uh, when,
when outcomes are, for example, noisy and when, and
which is, uh, causing some success is basically purely
due to the luck, you know, so, uh, you
might like, oh, I'd like to, I'd like to
follow this person uh because, you know, this one
seems really successful, but this The, the fact that
this person is very successful might be, might have
been just by, by the luck and then in
that case, copying what, what this person has done
might not be so informative, right? So, so there's
some like obviously this kind of cost of uh
copying the pay-based social learning, but um. Yeah, or,
or also, I mean, I don't know if this
is relevant to what you were saying there, but
I was just thinking that maybe, I mean, sometimes
celebrity, I mean we tend to associate celebrities to
success in some way, whether it is financial success,
social success, or whatever, but I mean if a
celebrity is trying to sell us a product and
they claim, OK, this is going to cure your
skin disease, I mean maybe the fact that they're
a celebrity should be, or I mean people should
treat that as irrelevant to their sort of medical
knowledge because they don't have any, I mean you.
Right, so I, I mean how do people deal
with that kind of information? I mean, do people
tend to just blindly follow anything that a highly
successful person tells them, or do they, or are
they more careful and perhaps they think, oh, OK,
maybe Cristiano Ronaldo. He's trying to sell me a
health product, but he's not a medical doctor, so
maybe I should be careful when it comes to
what he tries to sell. I mean, how does
it,
so it might be good reason to listen to
him, but, um, uh, yeah, in general, whenever we
have Any sort of behavioral bias, not only like
social learning biases, but also any, any decision making
biases, then surely that uh the market or economic,
economic dynamics uh might uh try, try to Relate,
like utilize this bias uh in, in the uh
kind of in the interest of some uh stakeholders.
So, um, in generally speaking, we should be, uh,
yeah, kind of aware, uh, maybe it's this is
why, uh, I think education like economics and psychology
is, uh, a good, good thing to teach because
um. Yeah, we, maybe it's important to recognize uh
that human, human behaviors are full of bias and
and it's usually works very well and this is
why we have, uh, the nature have evolved us,
uh, this, uh, this bias in the first place.
But obviously there's, it, it's usually comes with some
cost or some come comes with some downside of
this, having this bias and. Yeah, so it's in
generally like it's good things to have some meta-cognition
or some kind of think about why, why we
are interested in this and why we are kind
of tend to. Yeah, but, but it's if it's,
I think it's very difficult usually because these biases
might be just eliciting without even realizing it. So,
um. But yeah, and But for the this prestige
bias social learning case, I guess this is not
uh well. These social learning strategies we, I have
been talking about was usually has been focusing on
the informational benefit of social learning in general. So,
yeah, I was just talking about like because while
environment is uncertain and decision making is like very
difficult, so it's, it's a good idea to use
socially obtained information uh for this information purpose. Um,
BUT, uh, in this, especially, I guess, it, when
it comes to the prestige bias, social learning, uh,
there's another possible proximate, uh, motivation behind, uh, this
is probably like kind of more like a creating,
uh, Uh, social bonds like a, or like a
peer pressure sometimes like to, to, to show that,
uh, to show some kind of loyalty towards, uh,
the person, for example, or to, to have like
some, uh, to feel like a bonding with this
fandom, for example, you know, if you are a
big fan of, yeah, I'm a big fan of
Rolling Stones and Rolling Stones, uh, yesterday announced a,
like a new album. Yeah, and then I, I
like to wear this, for example, like a Stones
t-shirt. This is, well, this is not really like
a kind of prestige biased copying, but you know,
this sort of like a. Showing a feeling, the
feeling, uh, this, uh, unified uh community is another,
could be a possible, uh, driver, uh, where people
copy something, people follow some, someone's behavior for sure,
so yeah.
OK, so, but in our societies, I mean in
every single society, of course, people are not carbon
copies of each other. We have individual differences. So
how, how is it that we learn from others?
Despite our individual differences. I mean, how do, how
do we do that without having, for example, identical
goals and identical preferences? Right,
right, yeah, yeah, this is, this is my, yeah,
my favorite, yeah, the classic social learning research uh
that I have been talking about often. Usually assume
that we are individuals are all facing the same
problem basically with, with the same uh having uh
with the same reward function, uh maybe having reward
the same utility function, the freefra functions. But in
real life, as you said, that is not really,
that is never true actually, right? Like for example,
my, my, my favorite scotch whiskey may not be
your favorite. Or no, perhaps, perhaps you don't drink
whiskey at all,
do you? I mean in my personal case actually
I don't, I don't like alcoholic
beverages. OK, yeah, fair enough, fair enough, right? So
we have like a totally different preferences and, and
goals and stuff. Uh, SO yeah, so obviously my
best risky option is not necessarily your best option,
um, but that, that does not necessarily mean that
my experience is completely useless to you, uh, perhaps,
uh, but because we usually. May still share something
in common. For example, uh, yeah, let's say, let's
say you're, you're going to be visiting Tokyo, right?
And then you want to find a good, good
restaurant or good bar, you don't drink, drink, drink
at all. So, yeah, you, you want, let's say
you want to find a good restaurant and I
may know some good, uh, good restaurants in Tokyo.
Um, BUT yeah, then now my personal favorite, personal
list of my favorite restaurant. Is not necessarily the,
the perfect list for you, but you may have,
you know, because you, you, you have different tastes,
but, uh, but my list could still be useful,
um, because it may tell you what kind of
places. Uh, EXIST in the Tokyo and which neighborhoods
have interesting options, which neighborhood might be uh good
to visit, fun to visit, to, to explore restaurant
in general. Uh, SO my, although the exact, my
list is not, uh, fitting well with your taste,
but still the information I give is somehow could
be informative in some sense. So in other words,
Socially obtained information often contains both useful part and
useless components. So some parts are very very applicable
to your own goals and circumstances, but other parts
are just too specific to, to me, like to
the person who originally had that information. So, yeah,
so that in general, social learning should be beneficial
if, if you can somehow extract the useful part
from, from what you've just observed. So the, yeah,
the question in the key question here is then
like how, how could this, you know, how could
we do this job that differentiate between useful part
and uh unrelated parts.
And, and how do we do that? Do we
already have a good understanding of that or not?
Yeah, so this is like a kind of related
to my uh previous collaboration work with uh with
Alex Wit and Charlie Wu. Both were at the
time was in uh University of Tubingen in Germany.
Um, SO we, uh, there we put people, um,
in a simple decision making task where rewards, kind
of rewards differed across individuals, but rewards are still.
Positively correlated. So that means, like let's say this
is again the banded task, multi-banded task, but multiple
options and the options are kind of uh aligned
as a 2D map. So you can just imagine
a uh kind of 2D uh 2D map landscape
and, and then you, you don't know which corner,
which. The point of the map is very beneficial
for you. It's, it's matching well with your taste,
right? But you have this unknown, uh, to an
unknown restaurant list in the, in Tokyo, let's say,
right? And then. Then it might then uh each
participant has their, their own map, right? But in
Tokyo, and then of course which restaurant is best
for each participant, uh, it, it's different between participants,
but um they are still somehow correlated. Um, SO
that means, you know. So this creates the situation
where, uh, you know. It's still somehow, uh, you
know, the knowing others behavior might be still beneficial,
like still informative, but you, you shouldn't follow exactly,
uh, follow what others are doing, right? So, by,
uh, you know, having this sort of simplified abstract
version of, uh, uh, this social learning task, we,
uh, To, to capture the, the uh social learning
behavior of human participants, we've uh created a kind
of computational, uh, cognitive models called social generalization model,
uh, that captures that where we try to capture
this idea. Um, SO in this model, um. Uh,
THIS, this model uh captures, try to capture how
people might arbitrate between their own direct experience and
Uh, what others are doing. Social observations here are
useful, but they are kind of, you know, in
this model, this social observation is treated as a
noisier cue than than one's own experiments. So, you
know, this kind of Yeah, maybe I'm, I'm gonna,
uh, dive into a little bit mathsy part later,
but, um, in this social learning generalization model, uh,
we Um, model, computationally model this kind of arbitration
between Your own taste, your own experience, and others
observations, and then social observation is just treated as
a noisy cue. And then this noise capture the,
this kind of distance between my taste and your
taste. If, if you, if I treat your, if
I, if you, if I treat social observation noisier,
then which means I would think others are. Uh,
NOT very, very well matching with my taste. So
that's why I kind of give it more noise.
And then, so by, by doing so, we kind
of, we could capture the, uh, the human use
of this social generalization processes. And then, yeah, it
turns out like we kind of run online game
experiment and then fit this model to human uh
participants' behavior. And then we, we found that um
this model actually uh fitting very well with um
people's behavior. So, kind of, yeah, so, although this
is like uh, again, very abstract toy, um. Uh,
ABSTRACT decision making, uh, tasks, but, um, uh, at
least we can say that humans are still very
flexibly use social information, uh, adapt like even though
we are not necessarily, uh, having sharing the identical
taste.
Mhm. Yeah. Yeah, no, that, that's really fascinating, and
let me just say that, I mean, even if
I don't quite like alcoholic beverages, maybe sometimes I
would also like to know about uh alcohol or,
or about whiskey specifically because I might Have someone
who I want to be friends with who likes
whiskey and maybe then having that learning about what's
the best whiskey out there to give it as
a gift to that person and impress her. I
mean, maybe it's useful. I don't know.
Yeah, it's, it's good to explore new, uh, you
know, new dimensions, uh, that you haven't explored before.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. So, uh, let me ask you now
about, uh, collective decision making. So, uh, I mean,
I, I, I don't know if this is, uh,
or maybe it is a particularly Western thing. Uh,
I don't know if in Japan because you, uh,
live more, uh, in a more collectivistic society, if
People would actually think about this in different ways,
but we tend to, when, at least we in
the West, when we think about decision making, we
tend to focus a lot on individuals making decisions,
on individual decision making. But what is collective decision
making and how does it work?
Yeah, I see, yeah, that's, thanks for asking this,
uh, very interesting. I never thought, well, um, first
of all, like you mentioned about collectivism versus individualism,
like a cultural, uh, differences. Um, THIS, this sort
of dimensions might not be necessarily like aligned with,
uh, well with like uh collect patterns of social
learnings or patterns of collective decision making. Uh, FOUND
in, uh, in, for example, West and East societies.
Um, YEAH, but, so I was, uh, yeah, so
I'm gonna be talking about, uh, collective decision making,
um. And then, yeah, actually, um, well, this is
still like an ongoing work and it's not really
uh published yet. Um, BUT we recently um had
um kind of museum experiment conducted, uh, collaborating with,
uh, Max Planck, uh, Institute in Berlin people. And
we have like kind of very simple social learning
tasks. And that is implemented in this simple kind
of tablet PC. So it's quite easy PC like
a social learning task. And we implemented this task
in both Berlin Museum, uh, Science Museum in Berlin
and also Science Museum in, in Tokyo. And yeah,
we just kind of gather some data from, uh,
science museum goers and. It's a fantastic thing is
that there are a wide range of uh people
participating in, in our task, and there are age
ranges ranging from like uh toddlers or like uh
uh younger than 10 years old till like uh
more than 70 years young people, like the wide
range of uh people participated. And then surprisingly, we
found very interesting pattern like age. Uh, YOU know,
related to social learning patterns. Like, uh, usually, like,
roughly speaking, kids are like really, uh, using social
learning a lot and people, uh, kids are copying
others a lot. Whereas like teenagers, like uh like
in a starting. Just focusing on themselves and then
stop using social learning that much. And then this
social learning patterns coming back slightly as, as like
age is uh again going up. So this interesting
kind of U shaped pattern. IS very robust and
we found. Very similar pattern in both Berlin and
Tokyo. So, if like, I, yeah, so this result
itself might be a little bit um uh seemingly
inconsistent uh from some of the previous arguments, previous
uh suggestion that kind of collectivism, uh, individualism, uh,
and then like. Predict, uh, people's use of, uh,
social learning. Um, BUT, as, as long as at
least our data, uh, Uh, are not really consistent
with that argument. So, but yeah, obviously like there
might be like we, we still don't have good
theoretical understanding, uh, relationship between these two, collectivism, individualism
versus social learning views. So perhaps we have to
work on that. Uh, BUT, um, but yeah, sorry,
sorry about that. Um, I, then let me then
focus on, uh, what is collective decision making, um,
and how does it work. So. Collective decision making
is, so what happens when decisions of multiple individuals
combine. Uh, EITHER explicitly or implicitly to produce an
outcome at the group level. So, you know, that,
you know, this general definition includes. Uh, KIND of
familiar cases such as voting, discussion, deliberation, deliberative discussions,
committee meetings, or like a jury decisions, um, and
situations where the group needs to reach, uh, some
sort of consensus. But, uh, on the other hand,
collective decision making also includes, uh, many. Collective phenomena
where no, no explicit consensus is required, uh, such
as consumer behavior in the market or like non-human
animals, uh, fish school, um, swarm behavior, for example,
and, you know, or like social media trends, traffic
jams, and people joining, joining a queue for like
a lot of ramen shops and so on. But
in all of these like. Cases, individual decisions. Interact
Each other and then as a result, generating the
uh the large scale uh group level pattern. So
in a sense. Um, YEAH, I'd also like to
mention that in this sense, cultural evolution can also
be viewed as a, a form of collective decisions.
Um, YEAH, although, although these two topics have traditionally
been studied. Uh, SOMEHOW separate, uh, somewhat separate academic
disciplines as academic communities. Um, BUT for me, like
cultural evolution asks. How behaviors or how ideas, technologies
or social norms spread and disappear over time among
the population. And yeah, which falls, you know, which
fits nicely with uh the definition of collective decision
making. And although it's, it's time scale uh might
be, you know, longer in culture compared to the
some animal like a collective behavior and fat fat
and fashion dynamics of collective behavior. Yeah.
00, OK, so do you think that there would
be an avenue or a potential avenue to explore
in trying to combine the literature in cultural evolution
or cultural evolution, cultural evolutionary theory and the work
on collective decision making.
Mhm, YEAH. I think that's um the key here
would be um. I think again, like mathematical approach
would be key. I'd say, uh, especially, um, I
mean, like partly uh the collective, collective animal behavior
people have been doing this job very well. Um.
You know, in the collective, collective animal behavior literature,
you know, there are, there are researchers studying ants,
there are researchers studied honeybees, you know, there, there
are other people studying cockroaches or then like a
fish school and other mammal, uh, primate behavior and
so there are various different systems, but, uh, they're
like. Collective behavioral, uh, camp they they have been
doing like kind of applying a very simple, uh,
abs again, very abstract but the abstract level, uh,
dynamical model into, uh. That, that can capture that
wide range of different systems in, in a mathematical
form and then uh try to uh make sense
of seemingly totally different systems and different behavior, but
we can still understand some essence underneath of that
through the uh very simplified uh mathematical formula and
I think we can still, we can then. Understand
Uh, and then, of course, culture evolutions, culture evolution
has also a similar tradition as well. The cultural
evolutionists, uh, have Kind of developed a very nice
formal models to capture a different uh range of
Uh, different cultural evolutionary dynamics and systems. Um, SO,
I think it's already like we can just compare
these two mathematical forms and then usually, sometimes it's
really similar. So sometimes like terminology might be different,
but mathematically speaking, it's could be the mostly the
same thing. So, in this sense, unifying uh these
two systems is, you know, it's already like uh
have been. Uh, HAVE been worked on by, uh,
the, the researchers. Um, BUT still like, yeah, so,
but. Even I guess maybe maybe due to the
gap between the time scale, like usually cultural evolution,
people are interested in Galunga uh time dynamics, time
evolution, yeah, and, and then this would also involve
some uh demographic. Transitions as well, like some member
of the society is transitioning by like a demographic
dynamics. I think this part and then then which
then which drives longer term gene culture co-evolutionary processes
as well. So, culture evolution could tend to uh
have more like a genetic evolutionary. Uh, EFFECT as
well. Yeah, compared to, uh, just the collective behavior,
but yeah, this is also, uh, uh, probably, uh,
many people might be, uh, disagree with me, but.
Um, But like still, I, I guess these two
systems are usually the same thing and it's just
a matter of the time scales and yeah.
No, no, yeah, that, that's really a, a, a
fascinating insight. I, I guess that perhaps the are
many times the issue with implementing such, uh, I,
I mean, I mean, trying to integrate information or
knowledge from different kinds of, uh, uh, I mean,
coming from different academic communities, sometimes the issue there
is that. Uh, WE have this sort of, uh,
departmental disciplinary approach to science and knowledge and Uh,
many times it is really hard on an academic
level for people to, uh, cross communicate and collaborate
with people from, I, I mean, sometimes it's even
considered another discipline or people are working in even
in another department and sometimes people possibly are. NOT
aware of the theoretical foundations and the methodological framework
used by their colleagues that are working on other
topics or in even what is considered another discipline,
right? So there, there are, uh, it's unfortunate, but
there are some constraints there, right.
Yeah,
Uh, so, uh, let me ask you now about,
uh, crowds, because I mean, there's these very pervasive,
I, I mean, I, I'm, I, I'm not sure
if it's pervasive necessarily among academics, but it's, uh,
I, I mean in society in general, it's a
very pervasive idea that Uh, the idea of the
madness of crowds, that crowds, uh, go, go mad
sometimes, and then there's these crazy ideas about, for
example, a mass psychosis and all of that, but
I mean, what do we know about how crowds
tend to behave? I mean, are crowds usually wise
or mad?
Yeah, right. Yeah, like your, your view is exactly
the, the view from like, uh, the view of
the traditional social science, science view of the crowds.
Like, yeah, like, yeah, it's, I think traditionally speaking,
social science, the main agenda, one of the main
goal of, uh, goals of social science, uh, uh,
uh, from my view is, was, um, to understand.
Uh, THE, the, the why, why crowds are so
behave badly. And so this is why, yeah, and
then exemplified by uh the famous, uh, the book
written by like a journalist, Scottish journalist, uh, Charles
McKay. Uh, HE, he wrote a, like a Collective,
uh, madness of crowds and collective illusion, madras. And
then in that, in that book, he kind of
listed, uh, like a coup list of interesting, uh,
case, case study where human societies went into kind
of madness of crowds, such as like a very
classic, yeah, tulip, uh, bubble markets uh in Netherlands.
Uh, OR, you know, the, the, um, England, uh,
like, uh. Stock market bubbles. Uh, SO this, um,
yeah, this kind of seemingly, uh, malfunctioning of society,
um, was the, has been the focus, main focus
of the social science. I guess this is understandable,
uh, because, you know, usually, uh, we don't pay
attention to Uh, the system that is working very
well. We, we don't, we don't really even realize
this is working well. Uh, WE just, we just
kind of, uh, feel that this is just, uh,
just a normal state and this is, uh, you
know, it should be. And then when it's got
stuck, we realized, oh, what, what happened and why
this isn't working well. So, yeah, uh, but which
actually means that collective system works surprisingly very well.
Uh, uh, IN a wider range of situations, of
course, then sometimes it's. BEHAVING very badly. Um, YEAH,
but having said that. Um, ACTUALLY, um, It's really,
I'd say. That I, I'd not say crowds are
usually wise. Uh, BECAUSE I, and then I'd say.
I'd say crows, human crows or animal crows have
the potential to be wise under the right conditions.
Um, YEAH, the classic wisdom of crowds idea. Works
very well when. When individuals have diverse. A diverse
opinions and at least partly independent information so that
individual level, uh, individual error errors can, can be
canceled out each other by by merging these independent
informational input. But, uh, real crowds are usually very
interactive. People watch each other, you know, influence, influencing
each other. And people copy others' behavior, so that
kind of interactions are everywhere and which can improve.
And then You know, this is social learning, so
this interaction can in general improve the performance. But
At the same time, uh, this social interaction would
violate the, the, the, the requirement for the wisdom
of crowds. So because this usually reduce the diversity
of the opinions, independence of the opinions. So, yeah,
therefore, like, it seems like uh social interaction is
kind of a double-edged sword. So this can work
very well or work very bad. And then I
guess, so this is, has been one of my
kind of key questions in my uh past uh
research. Yeah, this like under what circumstances this social
interaction uh due to social learning can can mostly
promote collective intelligence and, and under what circumstances. Uh,
THIS collective and social learning processes is, uh, kind
of detrimental in terms of, uh, collective decision making
performance.
Uh, uh, BUT I mean, in what circumstances can
collectives demonstrate, uh, what is called maladaptive herding? I
mean, uh, when does that happen?
Yeah, so Then, yeah, I went to uh so
this is another my kind of collaboration work with
uh my um collaborator um in, in University of
Saint Andrews um. So Again, so according to the
wisdom of the crowd's idea, it might be, it
seems to be a key to understand, uh, under
what circumstances, uh, people, people rely more on others'
opinion. People rely on uh copying and under what
circumstances people kind of are still uh balanced, well
balanced between individual learning and copying. Then, uh, yeah,
then the previous research have suggested that people are,
well, people are very flexible about, uh, this use
of social learning. And previous theory suggests that people
might rely more on social learning when the, the
situation is, becomes uncertain and the group. The size
of the, the number of other people you are
interacting with increased. And so we simply like manipulate
these two things, like, you know, then, then we
observed what happened at the group level behavior. So
we, again, this was an online game experiment. And
where we, we changed the, we controlled the difficulty
of the task as well as uh we controlled
the the size of the group, each group size
and then. And then we studied two things. So
one is how individual people would react, react to
these different environments, how, how people change their social
learning behavior. In this changing, uh, uh, different, uh,
uh, combination of environmental setup. And then the second
one, we focused on was, as a result of
that, what kind of group behavior emerged. So, and
then we found that like surprisingly, um, When like
group size is large, become large and uh task
was difficult, people start like relying on stronger conformity
bias. And then as a result, People get stuck
uh in the more, more likely to get stuck
in the suboptimal option due to this heavy reliance
on conformist social learning. Whereas like when task was
not so difficult and group size is moderate, people
are still kind of uh flexibly, like a group
level behavior, it's still uh flexible. So Yeah, so
the Collective intelligence and madness, uh, is actually, uh,
somehow again, within this simplified framework, uh, but we
could, um, probably we could predict the, the, the
How um we could predict the behavioral patterns of
given collective uh group by, by estimating, uh, the,
by estimating individual level decision making strategies. So, there's
a like a very Uh, predictable linkage between individual
level versus, uh, individual level and group level behavior.
And then this linkage could be, uh, quantifiable by,
uh, experimental method.
Mhm. Uh, SO, but, uh, uh, that flexibility that
you mentioned there, is that one of the aspects
that, uh, sort of regulate the wisdom of crowds?
I mean, is the ability to remain flexible that
allows for a collective to be wise,
or? Yeah, I, yeah, this is, so there, there,
there must be multiple different definitions of what is
wise, but, uh, at that, in that study, we
defined like a collective, we, we kind of focused
on aspect of collective intelligence, uh, that is, uh,
kind of how adaptive the groups are, like how
adaptively. Uh, CHANGE their behavior, but, but to, to,
to react to the environmental, changing environment. So, for,
for, for, from, uh, for us, it, it wouldn't
be so collective intelligence if Group might be performing
very well at the fast, uh, at the initial,
you know, state, but if they get stuck in
this single behavior, even after the environment has changed,
then, uh, we, we define this as a kind
of inflexible, and then we define this as a
harding effect, uh, you know, it's like a animal
group, uh, gather, you know, behaving together as a
hard. So Harding effect is easily like kind of
emerging when when social lining is too strong. So
this is like a byproduct of having this strong
social lining.
Mhm. OK, great. So, I mean, let, let me
just ask you one last question. Uh, THIS just
came to mind because I guess that many people
who will be listening to our interview, our conversation
would, I, I, I, I mean, would want to
ask you this. I know that this is probably
not something that you've been working on directly, but
do you think that this, uh, the literature that
comes from Studying collective decision making and uh what
we call the wisdom and madness of crowds could
apply to understanding political phenomena. I mean, because I'm
asking you that because, you know, many times that's
one of the most immediate things that come to
people's minds. I mean, like I I I don't
know, sometimes people even apply it to the. COVID
pandemic, other times they apply it to uh extreme
political movements to uh the rise of the Nazis
and the fascists and all of that to uh
genocides that have been committed across history. So do
you think that uh there could be insights coming
from this literate literature that would help us understand
these kinds of phenomena?
Right, right. Yeah, yeah, this is like a big
question. So I don't think I can, I can
give a, an answer within this uh time. But
um let me try. um. Yeah, I, I think
so. Yeah, I, I, I think, yeah, we can
provide some insights or, and which comes from. Like,
so far, like what, what we have, what we
have found in general so far from this uh
project of social learning and collective decision making was
that. Social learning strategies, social learning is Beneficial because
social learning works as a tour guide, like a
guide, exploring, like a guiding you to like a.
Efficient exploration rather than, rather than that, uh, rather
than social learning being giving you uh a right
answer, immediate answer, right? So, you know, based on
my, my past research or also based on other
uh researchers from uh our communities, um, social learning,
social learning. Tells you like. Which direction of, uh,
which area of decision space is worth exploring? Or
what kind of, uh, what kind of, uh, you
know, the direction or area is, is worth checking
in, in your, in your future exploration. And then,
yeah, there's the one very, my, my favorite study
coming from honeybee study, honeybees, uh, nest site selection.
And yeah, so honey bees in the uh in
I, I guess many of, many of you, uh,
uh, you people already know familiar with honeybees are
really good at choosing the nest when they are
kind of swarming in the Aria spring, right? And
then they are remarkably good at choosing the. Better
new nest site and they can do that by
like a scout bees, inspect possible sites and communicate
through uh through this finding via famous wagu dances,
right? Uh, SO at the first glance, now because
they are interacting with each other via wagu dancing.
So this seems to be like violating the, the
requirement for wisdom of crowns, right? Because obviously they
seem to be interactive, which means they should be,
uh, the diversity of opinions might be reduced by
this interaction or independency might be also reduced, right?
So they are interactive. But key insight from the
honeybees is that. Actually, Wagguri dances, even though wurri
dances guide. Where other bees should inspect, right, but
this vari dance does not impact. How each followers
evaluate the the visiting site. So if you are,
if you're following, following B, you know, you, you
might go to the direction suggested. Once, once you
visit the, the direction, basically it's, it's you who
um evaluate the, the quality of the nest and
then. It's mostly like independent, independent from the social
impact. So, this combination of Uh, exploration being shaped
by social interaction, whereas like, Investigation or like evaluation
or belief updating itself is still independent. So this
com this like a right combination uh is the
kind of primal uh primary source of uh the
driver of honeybee swarm uh collective intelligence. I guess
this lesson should be applicable widely to uh non-honeybees,
uh, societies as well. So I guess humans. Yeah,
because social learning, if social learning, uh, is leading
you to new exploration, uh, direction, but you can
still, uh, learn things, decide things, uh, mostly independently
from others' opinion. So, I think this, uh, any,
any ways to, uh, Make, make sure, uh, any
ways to, uh, if, if there's any way to,
uh, promote this this type of com combination, this
type of balance between independence and interdependence, then, uh,
I guess, um. Yeah. That that this lesson should
be, I guess, widely applicable and then hopefully including
like a more political um dynamics or socio socioeconomic
uh dimension as well.
Great, so just before we go, would you like
to tell people where they can find you and
your work on the internet?
On the internet, yeah, you can find our work,
uh, by, by visiting Tokyo and you can like,
uh, just, uh, send me an email and you're
more, more than welcome to visit us in Tokyo,
but otherwise, you can visit, uh, yeah, maybe that
website. Uh, WE have a website and we usually
update, uh, what's going on. So, yeah.
OK, great. So Dr. Toyokawa, thank you so much
for taking the time to come on the show.
It's been a fascinating conversation.
Thank you, God. It was fun.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoro, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Lere, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Ebert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David
Pinsov, Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A
special thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank,
Lucas Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller,
Thomas Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro,
Al Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and
Rosie. Thank you for all.